madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20h
du nouveau ce soir dans la sphère de la
petite élise enlevée par sa mère et
retrouvée en hongrie
le père qui a pu rentrer avec ça si en
france souhaite une solution négociée
avec son ex femme c'est ce qui nous a
déclaré il ya quelques minutes nous
serons avec lui dans ce journal
nous serons par ailleurs en direct avec
la secrétaire d'état à la famille nadine
morano qui envisage un projet de loi
pour éviter que ce type de scénario ne
puisse se reproduire et nous en dira
plus dans le reste de l'actualité les
pêcheurs sont en colère ils bloquent ce
soir les ports de boulogne calais et
dunkerque ils réclament une augmentation
de leurs quotas de pêche
nous parlerons aussi nous répondrons à
toutes vos questions concernant les
plaques minéralogiques avis elles seront
visés dès demain sur tous les véhicules
neufs achetés
nous parlerons de l'impressionnante
surmortalité causée par la rudesse de
l'hiver on a recensé en france dans les
premières semaines de l'année 6000 des
faits en majorité des personnes âgées et
enfin à l'étranger nous irons à cuba où
une page de l'histoire est peut-être en
train de se tourner le président barack
obama a levé les restrictions sur les
voyages et certains investissements dans
l'île vingt-quatre jours après son
enlèvement à arles la petite elise
retrouvée avec sa mère en hongrie a pu
rentrer en france avec son père
elle passera à sa nuit avec son père
dans un lieu tenu secret pour des
raisons de sécurité pour des raisons
calme aussi et tout simplement pour
l'équilibré de l'enfant
nous étions avec eux dans l'avion du
retour zine dine de daoud jacques dubos
l'amour d'un père pour son enfant depuis
leurs retrouvailles air élise ne
quittent plus guère les bras de son papa
dans quelques minutes à peine ils vont
s'envoler pour la france tous les deux
on peut vous dire monsieur andré sur
votre retour en france
jean michel andré ne veut pas s'exprimer
avant d'avoir quitté la hongrie ce matin
à l'aéroport de budapest
des membres de l'ambassade de france
escorte la petite fille et son père aux
cases où la tension est palpable jean
michel andré redoute un nouvel
enlèvement nous a affirmé avoir reçu des
menaces anonymes provenant de moscou
finalement en début de matinée
l'embarquement se fait sans encombre
direction paris dans l'avion élise ne
semble pas traumatiser par le rap dans
sa propre mère est soupçonnée elle est
souriante et joue comme une enfant
la fillette est pourtant déchirée entre
ses deux parents en instance de divorce
à l'arrivée à paris la discrétion
prévost des policiers assurent leur
tranquillité en fin d'après midi
seulement après avoir fait étape à lyon
le père et sa fille arrive à marseille
tout près de chez eux
fatiguée pendant va élise ça va les
fatiguer aussi s'intéresser tout on a
beaucoup voyagé
c'est pas la première fois qu'un voyage
de les conditions disons d'inhabituel
donc ça va quoi aspirez-vous maintenant
nous reposer et puis nous remettre au
travail pour trouver une solution et ce
sont absurdes
jean michel andré soit désormais un peu
de tranquillité la maman delhi se trouve
toujours en garde à vue en hongrie et on
va retrouver maintenant à marseille où
il est arrivé le père d'élise jean
michel andré avec sa fille dans les bras
bonjour monsieur andré bonsoir vous ma
première question concerne votre fille
élise est ce qu'elle va bien ça a l'air
d'être le cas apparemment oui ça va de
mieux en mieux
elle retrouve même sens de l'humour elle
peut même faire une grimace crocodiles
non on ne veut pas le faire alors messi
andres que de sottes est ce que est ce
que votre fille élise comprend ce qui
s'est passé comment vous l'avez expliqué
on n'en est pas encore aux explications
je la fais parler elle me raconte
beaucoup de choses à la nuit noire de
tous depuis le jour de l'agression
et puis on le voit qu'il ya des choses
qui s'explique pas on m'a trouvé des
réponses en étant au plus près de la
vérité et en étant très progressif en
même temps alors je donne justement en
parlant de de réponse
elle a retrouvé son père mais elle à
nouveau perdu sa mère ce n'est pas
forcément une victoire pour l comment
est ce que vous comptez résoudre ce
conflit est ce que vous êtes prêt ce
soir à tendre la main à l'image que j'ai
déjà vous voyez exactement les mots que
j'ai employé déjà c'est pas une victoire
et un moment ils sont pas pas c'est pas
sa mère que je peux parler vous
comprenez dans quelle situation ils se
trouvent
c'est les autorités françaises des
autorités russes
avec mon entière collaboration pour
trouver une solution pourrait vous mais
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à changer
est-ce que vous êtes prêts ce soir à
tendre la main à sa mère à retirer votre
plainte par exemple oui mais c'est pas
forcément d'un point de vue juridique la
mais la meilleure des choses à faire
si c'est une question du point de vue du
symbole je n'ai pas de plainte contre sa
mère
d'accord voilà donc on va faire le mieux
pour trouver une solution pour pourrez y
trouver une solution pour élise ça veut
dire aussi trouver une solution pour ça
mais ça va de soi est-ce que vous
accepter l'idée par exemple qu'il y ait
un procès pour cet enlèvement dont vous
avez été la victime en france ou est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous
n'accepterez pas quoi qu'il arrive mais
ce n'est pas un menu à bois la voyez on
en est revenu quelques mois en arrière
je parle trop et elle me demande
d'arrêter
voilà donc on va on va s'arrêter
la justice n'est pas un menu
en tant qu' en tant que plaignant entre
guillemets on a une voix au chapitre
mais la justice suit son cours il faut
trouver une solution beaucoup plus
inusuelles est beaucoup plus général et
que tout simplement retiré sa plainte
si je retirer ma plainte ça changerait
pas grand chose en tout cas une solution
négociée
merci monsieur andré d'avoir accepté de
prendre un peu de tension au sol une
retrouvaille soit du monde avec votre
fille et puis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions bon courage je vous remercie
merci merci à vous tous et certains
thériault a été enregistré il ya
quelques minutes justement pour que la
petite élise qui trouvait que son père
parlait trop puisse retourner au calme
le plus rapidement possible alors on l'a
dit elle a retrouvé son père mais elle a
aussi perdu à nouveau sa mère que va
devenir cette dernière sera t-elle
libérés par les autorités hongroises
transféré en france pour être jugés pour
enlèvement
cela dépendra en partie de l'attitude du
père qui ils gagnent nous le dira semble
vouloir une conciliation
fanny stand mère irina belenkaya saura
demain si elle ressort libre du tribunal
de budapest ou si elle part en prison
interpellé dimanche entre la hongrie et
l'ukraine la jeune femme attend que les
autorités hongroises décide de son sort
sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt
européen son transfert vers la france
pourrait prendre plusieurs semaines ne
sont pas fixés aujourd'hui ils dépendent
de plusieurs choses notamment le point
de savoir si madame belenkaya va
accepter sa remise ne va pas l'accepter
donc la procédure peut durer
plus ou moins longtemps soupçonné par la
france de soustraction d'enfant à de
violences volontaires
la jeune femme risque plusieurs années
de prison mais dans son pays elle a
obtenu la garde de sa fille de la part
de la justice russe il n'y a aucun
accord entre paris et moscou est ce
sujet à dossier devenu diplomatiquement
sensible
nous pensons que la décision des
autorités hongroises de rendre la
fillette aux français sur ce que
précipiter solution souhaitée par les
deux états la médiation c'est à dire un
accord à l'amiable entre les deux
parents pour la garde de la fillette
on est en contact nous avec les
autorités russes et les autorités des
deux pays peuvent essayer de convaincre
le père et la mère d'essayer de se
mettre d'accord pour trouver une
solution dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
l' équilibre de la petite fille n'est
plus une affaire privée mais devient
aussi une préoccupation politique alors
le cas d'élise est très particulier mais
pas unique nadine morano la secrétaire
d'état à la famille a fait savoir
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait eu l'an
dernier en france 250 déplacements
conflictuels d'enfants dans le cadre de
couples binationaux qui se séparent elle
est avec nous en direct bonjour madame
morano
comment peut-on éviter que ce type de
situations tragiques ne se reproduisent
alors nous avons pris une mesure qui
sera discuté dans le cas du projet de
loi sur l'autorité parentale et les
droits des tiers
s'agissant des titres d'identité parce
que vous le savez pour obtenir un
passeport ou une carte d'identité ou une
autorisation de sortie du territoire la
signature d'un seul des parents suffit
avec ce texte il faudra la signature des
deux parents
c'est pour prévenir notamment le fait de
pouvoir emmener son enfant à l'extérieur
du territoire français sans que l'autre
n'en soit informé madame morano faudra
absolument avoir cette signature des
deux parents ça c'est valable quand les
parents s'entendent bien peut-être que
quand la petite élise avait son
passeport il aurait signé tous les deux
le problème c'est quand ça se passe mal
après avec le passeport existe le
problème de la petite hélice est d'abord
qu'elle a la double nationalité
donc nous voyons bien que c'est vrai que
dans le cadre de double nationalité
les choses se compliquent nous avons
pour remédier à ce genre de dispositif
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure 250
enfants enfants ont fait l'objet de
déplacement à l'étranger de déplacement
conflictuelles qui ceux qui se sont
résolus grâce à une médiation
internationale qui a été menée par le
service du ministère de la justice et
donc pour faire face à ce genre de
situation est bien plus de 85 pays ont
ratifié la convention de la haye qui
permet d'avoir cette médiation
internationale la france par ailleurs
assigné aussi des conventions
bilatérales avec une quinzaine de pays
dont trois pays du maghreb et ainsi
qu'avec l'egypte d'ailleurs donc les
solutions en matière de conventions
bilatérales permettent aussi de résoudre
des problèmes mais encore une fois vous
le savez rien ne résoudra mieux que les
problèmes les problèmes que de voir des
parents câbles sont rares les de
s'entendre et de prendre en compte
d'abord l'intérêt supérieur de leur
enfant parce que ce dont il faudrait
parler aussi
ce sont les graves problèmes
psychologiques auxquels après sont
confrontés les enfants une heure madame
la petite élise l'objet de trois
enlèvements
en trois ans je pense que c'est très
grave pour pour ses enfants une toute
dernière question très rapidement vous
parlez de médiation du ministère de la
justice est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
la justice française renonce à toute
poursuite contre la mère si jamais il ya
un accord entre le père et la mère
écoutez d'abord on ne peut présager de
rien il y a des contacts qui sont pris
entre le ministère des affaires
étrangères le ministère de la justice de
notre pays et le ministère russe
il y a bien évidemment des discussions
une médiation qui va s'engager
je recevais pour ma part vendredi une
député russe à mon cabinet natalia
karpowicz dont on voit bien aussi du
côté de ce pays la volonté de pouvoir
dégager des conventions bilatérales avec
plusieurs pays merci beaucoup madame
morano d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions dans le reste de l'actualité
on va parler maintenant de la colère des
pêcheurs les ports de boulogne calais et
dunkerque sont bloqués ce soir et avec
eux le trafic maritime sur la manche
ils réclament une hausse des quotas de
pêche pour la france mais les
discussions semblent dans l'impasse le
ministre michel barnier estime que le
problème c'est que je cite les pêcheurs
du nord ont trop de bateaux
caroline tvo c'est l'un des derniers
ferry a quitté le port de calais ce soir
il n'y a plus de trafic à travers la
manche
une vingtaine de chalutiers a envahi le
chenal à 16 heures dunkerque et boulogne
sur mer sont également paralysés
on a c'est de négocier pour l'instant
les portes sont fermées bon s'il faut au
déblocage dur pour les gens se mettent
autour d'une table on fera des blocages
2 dès ce matin les marins bloquer les
routes autour des quais leurs
revendications pouvoir pêcher plus de
cabillaud et de sole le quota du premier
semestre est déjà atteint avec deux mois
d'avancé
bal à savoir qu'on n'a pas de solution
là il faut savoir qu'on a pu de coton à
l'heure actuelle quoi on est le
troisième mois de l'année puis on n'a
plus rien à pêcher c'est à dire que le
bateau à saclay en mer du poisson il y
en a même les scientifiques
reconnaissent que le cabillaud est
redevenu abondant dans certaines zones
mais pour préserver l'avenir de l'espèce
il faut distille maintenir les quotas
une bonne partie de ces cabillaud qui
sont relativement jeunes qui sont certes
au dessus de la taille marchande on qui
sont commercialisables réglementairement
parlant mais qui sont encore trop jeunes
pour être en capacité sur le problème
la france avait déjà obtenu 30% de plus
pour ces quotas cette année la
commission européenne refuse pour
l'instant toute nouvelle rallonge
il ya quelque chose qui va changer dans
les rues et sur les routes dès demain en
soi ce n'est pas grand chose mais pour
tous les automobilistes ce sera une
révolution les premières plaques
d'immatriculation à vie feront leur
apparition sur les véhicules neufs
alors pour qui pourquoi comment réponse
à toutes ces questions avec juliette
guérin et chloé cormery adieu le vieux
système français d'immatriculation après
59 ans de bons et loyaux services il
cède sa place aux nouvelles plaques
alors pourquoi ce nouveau système
d'abord parce que l'actuel fichier est
obsolète
il comporte 150 millions de dossiers
alors que seuls 40 millions de véhicules
seraient en circulation
le nouveau système est considéré comme
plus sûr avec un numéro attribué à vie
au véhicule
et une nouvelle carte grise réputés
sains falsifiable ce système devrait
rendre plus difficile le trafic de
voitures et puis un numéro à vie
c'est aussi un atout pour la sécurité
routière on va pouvoir assurer une
meilleure traçabilité du véhicule et
notamment vérifier que le contrôle
technique du véhicule qui est
indispensable pour vérifier le bon état
d'entretien il le fait que le véhicule
puisse rouler correctement que sur la
voie publique soit effectué en temps et
en heure quels sont les véhicules
concernés dès demain toutes les voitures
neuves mais aussi les motos et les
camions et à partir du 15 juin pour les
véhicules d'occasion mais seulement en
cas de changement de propriétaire ou
d'adressé
comment ça marche désormais plus besoin
d'aller à la préfecture lors de l'achat
le concessionnaire ou le garagiste se
connecte au système national
d'immatriculation qui délivre
automatiquement le numéro attribué à vie
au véhicule
je ne bougera plus menaçant les
changements département de propriétaire
ce vécu restera ce numéro un sera
jusqu'à la destruction le vendeur
installe les plaques et dans un délai
d'une semaine
vous recevez par courrier la nouvelle
carte grise alors vous l'avez compris le
numéro accordé à vie et rattachées au
véhicule pas au propriétaire vous
pourrez en revanche choisir au modifier
à volonté le numéro du département
qu'il s'agisse de celui vous habitez ou
tout simplement de celui qui a les
faveurs de votre coeur alors pour être
tranquille pendant l'été les parisiens
vont ils abandonner leurs 75
les corses les bretons les ch'tis
vont-ils envahir les autres régions
éléments de réponse donnée cet après
midi un peu partout en france
antoine gaveau un morceau de métal de 50
centimètres sur dix deux lettres trois
chiffres et à nouveau de l'être voici
les nouvelles plaques d'immatriculation
pas vraiment menaçante à première vue et
pourtant ce matin au feu rouge elle
faisait parler d'elle
ah ben je trouve très jolie ça me
convient parfaitement le premier tu mens
aucun sens
ça n'a aucun sens de changer
mais nulle pour pas épuisé
les numéros de département voilà
l'inquiétude pas de panique ils
apparaîtront bien à droite sous le logo
de la région
avantage on pourra désormais choisir son
numéro une façon de réaffirmer son
attachement à son département
prenez la sève et ses 33 non matière et
sur la plaque
mais sur la place partout 59 je ne
resterai jusqu'en france à cette voie là
sachant aussi c'est bien connu qu'un
automobiliste conduit toujours plus mal
ailleurs certains préféreront au
contraire une fausse identité
qu'on sera plus 75
en province
75 c'est considérer
enfin les conducteurs pourront être
frivole passion furtive ou amours déçues
pas de problème les changements de
numéros de départements sont autorisés
on pourra même ne pas en avoir du tout
on en sait plus ce soir sur les
motivations du forcené qui a tué deux
personnes hier dans le nord à douchy les
mines
âgé de 62 ans il aurait ouvert le feu
sur ses voisins parce que ces derniers
s'étaient garés devant chez lui
les victimes un jeune couple sont âgés
de 20 et 24 ans l'assassin avait bu au
moment des faits et selon d'autres
voisins il avait déjà été à plusieurs
reprises menaçant avec son arme
ils ont disparu aussi soudainement
qu'ils étaient apparus en thaïlande les
opposants au pouvoir ont rangé leurs
chemises rouges pour éviter distille le
bain de sang
du coup les fêtes du nouvel an qui ont
lieu en ce moment à bangkok ont repris
leurs droits dans une ambiance il faut
le dire un peu surréaliste sur place
arnauld miguet dominique marault tél à
la mi journée il ya les larmes
les chefs de l'armée rouge comme on
l'appelle ici ont décidé de rendre les
armes
ils avaient dit qu'ils nous frappent
très fort et ils l'ont fait c'est un
moment très difficile pour nous je vais
continuer à me battre pour la démocratie
les rouges ne meurent jamais la
démocratie ne meurent jamais les
partisans de l'ex premier ministre déchu
thaksin chinawatra s'en retourne
les chemises rouges sont ko debout
pourtant ce matin encore ils semblaient
tenir tête au pouvoir en place et après
six jours de guérilla urbaine à l'armée
thaïlandaise
thériault points chauds le parlement
tout un symbole et des barricades
tels ces bus en feu érigés par ceux qui
ne savent pas encore qu'ils sont ratés
leur révolution
du coup cet après midi c'était bataille
de pistolets à eau et larmes de joie
dans les rues d'une capitale qui peut
enfin fêter songkran le nouvel an
bouddhiste
un retour à la normale qui ne peut que
rassurer ses quatre touristes français
arrivés ce matin
et puis d
des rangées de pardonner de ce que ça
n'a pas du tout vers d'affairé
le gouvernement a donné deux jours
supplémentaires de vacances aux
thaïlandais le temps de rétablir la loi
et l'ordre
une fois pour toutes mais la situation
politique ici restent volatiles la
thaïlande n'en est pas à son premier
coup d'état ou à ses premiers
affrontements violents entre groupes
politiques dans ce pays la démocratie
reste une chose fragile
c'est peut-être une page de l'histoire
qui est en train de se tourner à cuba le
président obama a levé hier les
restrictions sur les voyages et les
transferts d'argent imposer aux citoyens
américains en direction de lille
une main tendue vers le régime castriste
disent les uns un piège pensent les
autres fidel castro a fait savoir
aujourd'hui qu'il ne demandait pas
l'aumône je cite mais la fin du blocus
qui paralyse son pays depuis maintenant
quarante six ans christian odin
aujourd'hui sur l'aéroport de la havane
des centaines d'américains d'origine
cubaine arrive comme chaque jour de
floride pour retrouver leurs proches
jusqu'à hier il ne pouvait faire le
voyage qu'une fois par an dorénavant ils
pourront se rendre à cuba
autant qu'ils le veulent c'est une très
bonne chose parce que c'est dur pour les
familles de devoir attendre tant
d'années avant de retrouver ceux qui
leur sont chers
depuis 2004 les restrictions concernant
les déplacements mais aussi les envois
d'argent plafonné à 100 dollars par mois
hier washington a annoncé qu'il n'y
aurait plus de limitations je pense que
le niveau de vie des cubains va
s'améliorer parce qu'il va y avoir
d'autres sources de revenus pour
l'économie
assouplir l'embargo c'était l'une des
promesses du candidat obama
il s'y était engagé devant la communauté
cubaine de miami
j'ai l'intention de tourner la page
il est temps d'en finir avec les paroles
qui ne donne aucun résultat dans la
presse cubaine ce matin fidel castro
affirme que ce geste ne suffit pas cuba
dit il ne tendra jamais la main pour
demander l'aumône
l'ex président veut la levée totale du
blocus qui frappe l'île depuis 1962 pour
les observateurs
l'arrivée de barack obama marque un
changement de méthode il ya la méthode
forte
militaire c'est la méthode des
républicains la méthode bush celle de la
négociation de l' influence c'est celle
des démocrates c'est celle du président
obama
donc si rupture il y aller dans la
méthode donc c'est pas rien mais ça ne
veut pas dire non plus que l'embargo va
être levé du jour au lendemain la suite
se jouera à la havane et devant le
congrès à washington
de nombreux républicains s'élèvent
contre ces mesures qualifiées de cadeau
sans contrepartie fait à la dictature
cubaine
les salariés de heuliez l'attendait avec
impatience la décision du tribunal de
commerce de niort
concernant l'avenir de l'équipementier a
été finalement reportée à demain matin
de source syndicale le redressement
judiciaire serait acquis autrement dit
et c'est à confirmer l'équipementier
éviterait pour l'heure la liquidation
il faut dire vous l'avez vu que de
nombreux élus régionaux de tous bords se
sont mobilisés sur ce dossier automobile
toujours avec cet incroyable paradoxe
lié à la crise et aux prix mises en tout
genre un véhicule neuf de moyenne gamme
est aujourd'hui plus intéressant pour un
acheteur qu'un véhicule d'occasion
à condition bien sûr d'envoyer son
ancienne voiture à la casse
résultat le marché de l'occasion qui
faisait le bonheur des petits budgets
fond à vue d'oeil
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé erik vasys un iris matthey un
ballet régulier devenu habituel dans
notre paysage sur ce camion des
véhicules en provenance directe des
concessions automobiles leur destination
cette casse de picardie que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui plus élégamment un centre de
recyclage
et pourtant
les voitures sont en état de marche des
petits modèles bon marché qui se vendait
jusqu'à lors d'occasions pour 1000 à
2000 euros
mais à présent puisque leurs
propriétaires ont touché la prime à la
casse
il faut bien se résoudre à les désosser
en fait la prime à la casse induit donc
une suractivité pour l'ensemble de la
filière de recyclage automobile soit +12
% prévus sur l'année 2009 ce qui
correspond à 200 mille tonnes d'acier
traiter également deux cent vingt mille
véhicules supplémentaires recycler plus
d'activité mais moins de profits avec la
baisse des cours de la ferraille le
compte n'y est pas la carcasse de
voiture c'est à dire l'élément acier qui
a récupéré une fois qu'on a exploité
cette valorisation de matières étaient
en prix moyen 2008 autour de 1180 euros
tonne départ aujourd'hui dans certaines
régions on est à moins de 18 euros tonne
départ de chine
en europe la demande d'acier a chuté
depuis la crise ce qui explique la
baisse soudaine des cours et la main
d'oeuvre
elle reste aussi essentiel pour le
démontage et donc le recyclage
aujourd'hui un véhicule et donc recyclé
à 85 % de son poids soit pour un
véhicule de eun sun 850 kg de matières
valorisé à l'autre bout de la chaîne
chez les concessionnaires les primes
s'accumulent sur les véhicules neufs
jusqu'à 2700 euros
alors forcément les occasions récentes
elles ne sont plus intéressantes elles
deviennent même encombrante le stockage
coûte en moyenne 15 euros par véhicule
et par jour
il est d'autant plus urgent de se
débarrasser des voitures de plus de dix
ans avant la prime à la casse en moyenne
ici à sarcelles on avait dix voitures
devant partir à la casse dans le mois et
là en a - là à vendredi dernier on en
avait soixante deux et trois jours après
il est venu en chercher est renvoyé le
parc est encore plein et nous en reste
nous voici dans les locaux d'un site de
vente en ligne de véhicules d'occasion
oui effectivement je confirme il ya une
réelle raréfaction
six véhicules ainsi pris ici le constat
est le même
l'effet prime à la casse fait
disparaître du marché des modèles qui
faisait le bonheur des petits budgets ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ces
véhicules de plus de 10 ans sont les
véhicules achetés par les jeunes qui
vivent leur permis la troisième ou
quatrième voiture du foyer et
malheureusement ces véhicules vont
directement la case ne peuvent pas être
repris sur le marché
et en plus ces véhicules là où une
valeur qui est bien supérieur aux mille
euros effet paradoxal la prime à la
casse a favorisé le marché du neuf est
agrippé celui de l'occasion un marché
pourtant cinq fois plus important un
chiffre maintenant terrible c'est une
estimation de l'institut de veille
sanitaire on a recensé en france dans
les premières semaines de janvier 6000
décès en majorité des personnes âgées
en cause un hiver particulièrement rude
avec des virus et des infections plus
présent que jamais valérie kg sylvain
d'hobart dans cette maison de retraite
près de paris les fonctionnaires n'ont
pas souffert des frimas de l'hiver des
recommandations précises avaient été
données j'ai demandé à mon équipe de
mettre l'accent sur la vigilance au
niveau du froid donc au niveau des
sorties et au niveau de l'alimentation
et l'hydratation d'autres personnes plus
isolés ont eu moins de chance avec des
températures inférieures à la moyenne
institut de veille sanitaire a recensé
début 2009 près de 6000 décès de plus
que la normale soit une hausse de 14%
trois facteurs expliqueraient
l'apparition fin 2008 de nombreuses
maladies respiratoires suivi d'une
épidémie de grippe et d'une vague de
froid
ces trois situations là ont fatigué les
organismes les ont déstabilisés ont
conduit à des situations
d'usure physiologique qui ont précipité
des décès à la mi janvier le nombre de
décès chez les personnes de 95 ans et
plus a même atteint un pic le plus
important depuis la canicule de 2003 il
ya aujourd'hui dans notre pays un grand
nombre de personnes âgées de personnes
très âgées de personnes fragilisées et
que nous sommes en retard par rapport à
nos voisins européens et nous avons un
effort de solidarité nationale à faire
en faveur de ces personnes
les cinq régions les plus touchées se
situent toutes au nord de la loire à
l'exception du languedoc roussillon
d'autres pays européens y compris des
pays froids comme la suède et le
danemark ont enregistré cet hiver là
même surmortalité les policiers des
hautes pyrénées près de tarbes recherche
un de leurs collègues ce soir il s'est
enfui après avoir tué par balles son
épouse et ses deux enfants dans leur
domicile familial à cabanac
le policier qui était aussi conseiller
municipal du village a laissé une note
indiquant qu'il souhaitait mettre fin à
ses jours sans plus de précisions sur
les raisons de son acte et on apprend à
l'instant que l'homme vient d'être
interpellé par des gendarmes il a été
neutralisé serait grièvement blessé on
n'en sait pas plus pour l'instant sur
les conditions de son arrestation parce
que la démographie des départements a
changé il est devenu nécessaire de
modifier la carte électorale
un exercice particulièrement sensible le
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
question affirme avoir opéré son
découpage en toute impartialité
il ya quelques minutes martine aubry a
fait savoir que les propositions étaient
inacceptables
tirez kurt et le député didier mathus
est un peu énervé et l'ubs réélu cinq
fois de suite en saône et loire
il vient d'apprendre que sa
circonscription va peut-être disparaître
fusionner avec celle de son voisin
socialiste comme lui de faire sauter
gauche adapté la carte électorale didier
mathus est d'accord elle n'a pas changé
depuis 23 ans et depuis la population
française a beaucoup changé mais il juge
le redécoupage du ministère de
l'intérieur partial je crois que c'est
du tripatouillage
une très grande ampleur parce que ça ne
respecte évidemment on pas les bassins
de vie les territoires naturels ni les
perspectives d'aménagement du territoire
et c'est une façon surtout de tricher
avec le suffrage universel
l'assemblée compte 340 députés de la
majorité
229 de l'opposition d'après les premiers
travaux publiés seulement neuf
circonscriptions de droite seraient
supprimés contre 23 de gauche
selon le journal le monde c'est surtout
dans le nord et le centre de la france
qu'il aurait le plus de coups de ciseaux
ces chiffres sont rejetés par le
gouvernement il ne serait plus
d'actualité
jeudi c'est de l'intox et du bricolage
bien ce document n'est pas fini donc je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment
certain nombre de gens en avoir des
copies mais pour le ps les intentions du
gouvernement reste bien celle d'un
découpage partisans malgré les
concertations préliminaire nous voyons
bien aujourd'hui que l' équilibre
n'existe pas et que la démocratie n'a
pas été respecté on a vraiment
l'impression que le gouvernement se fait
un véritable bouclier électoral pour
empêcher de faire en sorte que le vote
des français aille dans le sens qu'il
souhaite
cette question est ultrasensible chacun
prend ses marques avant les ultimes
arbitrages qui devrait démarrer la
semaine prochaine aux etats-unis la
terre de louisiane est chargé d'histoire
et c'est pour cela qu'elle a été choisie
par le réalisateur français bertrand
tavernier pour son premier film
américain
il sort en salles demain avec tommy lee
jones dans le rôle d'un antihéros qui va
devoir trouver son chemin dans la brume
électrique c'est le titre marie-jo
j'm'en vincent bouffartigue dans les
temps anciens on avait pour coutume de
poser de lourdes bien sur les tombes des
défunts pour éviter que leurs âmes ce
métal
tous remontés les vivants
j'espère que cette pauvre fille était
déjà morte quand il s'est mise à la
charité tournage dans la brume la vraie
celle de la louisiane du sud dans la
scène l'inspecteur dave robicheaux
découvre dans le bayou la victime d'un
tueur en série
prémices d'un polar classique pas
vraiment avec bertrand tavernier à la
caméra et le texan tommy lee jones en
flic rongé par l'alcool mais tellement
humain c'est du grand art j'ai tout de
suite senti chiche partait en voyage
avec des brebis chaud ça l'est un voyage
qu'elle est excitant qu'elle est
passionnant qu'il allait me faire faire
des découvertes formidable il me prenait
par la main et il m'emmenait dans un
monde et une disait regarde regarde
c'est beau c'est violent c'est étrange
jeune fils de 19 ans a été violée et
tuée il ya dans le sud
on dirait qu'on a à faire un psychopathe
aussi elle se mêle connaître si dave
robicheaux tracas serial killer
aujourd'hui il est aussi le témoin de
l'histoire de la louisiane
malmené par l'homme et les ouragans j'ai
perdu beaucoup d'amis
j'ai plein de souvenirs le texas est à
côté
j'adore la nourriture la musique du jeu
des gens aussi bien sur les mondes se
croisent un général de la guerre de
sécession conseil l'inspecteur lorsqu'il
doute quoi de plus normal ici le passé
est ancré dans la terre ils essayent de
vous dire regardez regardez moi et quand
vous m'aurez affronter peut-être que les
crimes du présent vous arriverez à les
résoudre
enquête policière passionnante où voyage
halluciné au coeur d'un pays meurtri
le film se lit à plusieurs niveaux la
volonté affichée de deux fortes
personnalités créatrice d'une oeuvre
majeure
culture toujours pour les amoureux de
l'afrique ou ceux qui veulent découvrir
ce continent magique je vous signale la
sortie du livre de notre confrère
richard bean et le sens du baobab aux
éditions riveneuve et sheikh binet et
grand reporter à france 2 il a couvert
de nombreux conflits en afrique
en tennis rien ne va plus pour les
français à monaco monfils mathieu simon
et serra ont été éliminés dès le premier
tour il reste un seul français en lice
marc gicquel il affrontera demain
l'espagnol ferrer avant de refermer
journal je vous en rappelle le principal
titre la petite élise et son père ont pu
quitter aujourd'hui la hongrie ils
passeront ce soir leur nuit au calme en
france dans un endroit tenu secret pour
la tranquillité des enfants par ailleurs
le père nous a affirmé dans ce journal
qu'il souhaitait trouver une solution
négociée avec sa mère toujours pour le
bien de l'enfant fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi à 20h35 ne
manquez pas le téléfilm dix fois celle
affaire salengro pour l'information
demain à 13h vous retrouverez sophie le
saint qui pour ma part je vous donne
rendez vous à 20h en attendant voici la
météo avec laurent romejko excellente
soirée sur france 2
l'info continue c'est aussi sur france 2
point fr